it's now 1300 GMT we begin with
developing news from Lebanon where
there's been renewed fighting in the
southern refugee camp this follows a
short-lived ceasefire among the fighting
Palestinian factions at least six people
have been killed in two days of fighting
the Lebanese Army has blocked off the
area and is preventing anyone from going
inside the camp
seems the situation will escalate
further inside the camp we heard about
ceasefire on more than one occasion but
no side is holding to it the situation
is dire families are dispersed here and
there my family has been locked out of
the camp for three days now security is
totally absent inside
we ran for our lives as shells and
bullets were flying over our heads until
midnight it was all calm but by two in
the morning fighting renewed it has
intensified since then we ran for our
lives leaving everything behind the
entire neighborhood was totally
destroyed people here are landing a
helping hand to us we pray for an end to
the
bloodsheda joins us now from the einel
have a refugee camp in Lebanon and zaina
the fighting is reported to have picked
up how's it looking now
foreign
well clashes are continuing if you can
hear behind me bursts of gunfire this is
day three of factional factional
fighting inside inside this Camp the
largest camp for Palestinian refugees
and as you can see it is densely
populated but people are hiding in their
homes tens of thousands of people live
here people are afraid efforts to reach
a ceasefire deal have so far failed
there have been meetings over the past
two days between palestinia and Lebanese
officials to try to put an end to the
latest bout of violence so far to no
avail what we understand is that the
fatah movement the mainstream
Palestinian faction which really is the
most powerful faction in this Camp is
demanding Fighters belonging to Jean de
Shem and other groups hand over the
killer of a fatah commander and his
companions so ongoing efforts to try to
forge a ceasefire so far to no avail
people are afraid because because the
stray bullets have been Landing in areas
and neighborhoods adjacent to the camp
and hundreds of families are now living
in mosques outside the camp so really
you have the makings of a possible
humanitarian crisis if this continues
zaina put it into context for us
especially for our International viewers
who might not be across all of these
details what sparked the trouble there
take us through the different factions
and the balance of power between them
try the cap the Lebanese authorities the
Army according to a long-standing
agreement does not enter Palestinian
camps there are 12 across across the
country there's a lot of lawlessness in
there a lot of arms people who are
wanted by the state they all seek
shelter inside einel hallway so these
factions have a history of animosity and
every now and then there is violence
there's clashes but this time around it
is quite serious it's deadlier than in
the past and it is more more intense
Palestinians have had a presence in the
country for decades this camp we call it
a camp it's no because it started as a
10th settlement back in 1948 when
Palestinians were forced to to leave
Palestine but today it is a built up
area and um and at the end of the day
Palestinians have been blamed for
playing a role if you like in the Civil
War before the Civil War in 1975 they
created a state within a state this is
how many Lebanese see their role in the
country so this is a very very sensitive
issue with some Lebanese politicians now
saying the Lebanese Army must act the
Lebanese Army must enter the camp and
disarm all the factions but we saw that
happen more than a decade ago you can
hear ongoing clashes more than a decade
ago in the north of the country in
another Camp when the Lebanese Army
engaged in months of of clashes really
with Palestinian factions which
destroyed the camp and left thousands
and thousands of Palestinians displaced
once again
all right thanks so much there